oui mais je te dire par un moment vous
citez un texte coup qualifiée d' indigne
de mitterrand et même si vous êtes
encore plus sévère ou effectivement je
sais je sais plus bien vous êtes très
très très violent le gain texte de
mitterrand où il compare de gaulle un
dictateur et finalement comparant à
pétain finalement c'est le coup d'état
permanent qui est un livre et je déteste
et je n'ai rarement rencontré mitterrand
sans lui rappeler que je détecte que je
ne pouvais pas supporter ce livre il
chaque fois il me laissais mon meilleur
livre bon c'était ça coupait court à la
conversation et en plus ça va être
hostile était très brillant très
brillant très brillant mais c'est un à
la limite de la famille parce que là
certaines comparaisons ne sont pas
supportables
bon alors écoutez évidemment c'est
divisible les jours à 3h du matin pour
être encore là pour parler parce que on
n'a pas parlé évidemment on aurait pu
parler de l'algérie on pourrait parler
des rapports de avec l'allemagne la
politique en afrique on pourrait ce qui
les rassemble ce qui veut dire on peut
jusqu'à 3 heures du matin si on veut
nous laisser la teinte 4h du matin
relations qu'on est là ils sont encore
passionnant mais moi ce que je veux dire
je peux donner aussi moralement c'est
que j'ai eu le privilège comme comme
vous gilles martin chauffier c'est de
lire ces deux livres en même temps j'ai
pris un plaisir extrême parce que c'est
évidemment deux grandes destinées qui se
recoupent qui s'opposent qui se
rassemblent qui c'est ça qui est
qu'extraordinaire moi je conseille aux
gens c'est de lire les deux livres en
même temps que c'est comme ça qu'ils se
font une idée sur le sur l'un et sur
l'eau alors bon sur la morale je voulais
qu'on parle évidemment de l'hédoniste de
mitterrand et downeast ce que de gaulle
était quand même très peu alors je dois
quand même qu'on parle aussi éhontée à
menad super je parle de la parole gilles
martin chauffier c'est que tous les deux
ils ont au départ voulu être écrivain
ils ont voulu être écrivain et d'une
certaine manière ils ont réussit pas
dans un domaine du roman
ils ont écrit des bouquins des mémoires
qui sont très remarquable et pour l'un
et pour l'autre
mais moi je n'ai dargaud ce sont marc
420 non non non je pense qu'en en tant
qu'écrivain je moi je
on n'en serait pour le fait que de
gaulle laissera dans l'histoire de la
littérature française une oeuvre plus
forte que les mois les mémoires de
guerre mitterrand laissera de trait
très brillant et très joli texte
notamment dans l'abeille et l'architecte
il ya notamment un portrait d'un arrêt
kissinger qui est une pure merveille en
15e personne ne peut écrire mieux même
le coup d'état permanent
wax et un oui je souhaitais je pense que
dans l'ordre même dans l'ordre de la la
chose littéraire je pense que en fin de
compte charles de gaulle je pense aura
quelques lignes de plus dans un
dictionnaire des littératures française
que françois mitterrand d'accord dans
les mémoires de guerre le pense à un
passage que je relis aujourd'hui dix
fois la la description du voyage et de
la rencontre du voyage à moscou du
général de gaulle et de la rencontre
avec staline est au top et fait partie
par des plus belles pages de la
littérature française par sa force
le portrait de staline extraordinaire la
négociation dans la nuit au kremlin
ce talent il c'est fabuleux c'est tout
tout n'est pas de même du même niveau
parce qu'il y a des aspects techniques
mais ces passages là celui là par
exemple mériterait d'être dans une
anthologie de la ligne de la grande
littérature française ce sont tous les
deux quand même faut dire l'un et
l'autre des pastiches à venir quand on
lit de gaulle on a concentré manque
avant d'écrire lit pendant quelques
heures du déshonneur du 17e siècle quand
on lit mitterrand sans qu'il a relu du
château voyant il ya une façon d'écrire
chez eux qui n'est pas du tout
contemporaine et dont on sent qu'il faut
ils font du beau français c'est ça ne
retire rien il ya des chroniques
merveilleuse de mitterrand mais à
wissant bétangeais ça n'empêche pas le
charme et la et ses livres sont
passionnants mais sait on sent que c'est
pas un style et la limonade huron proust
ou céline c'est muller et c'est pas leur
ambition d'ailleurs je pense que je
pense que leurs ambitions et être évincé
qu'ils auraient volontiers était aussi
poussé gré bon alors gilles martin
chauffier on va voir on reviendra ne
vois pas quel rebondissement dans ce
roman vous fait un portrait à la fois
corrosif et très amusant d'un certain
paris littéraire d'enceinte un pari
politique combinards mensonges et
corrompu sépare indignation doivent
écrit ce roman
oui tout à fait je trouve que la
corruption en france est extrêmement
grave qu'elle est extraordinairement
répandu qu'on envoie des traces tous les
jours en particulier la corruption je
vais dit bien d'un classe politique que
on dit toujours mais c'est un
financement de partis politiques il
n'est pas d'enrichissement personnel je
crois que c'est faux je crois qu'un
enrichissement personnel
extraordinairement répandue qui se
manifeste ou une foule de forme qui vont
des appartements de fonction au rapport
de complaisance qui sont payés alors
qu'ils ne sont pas rédigés qui vont
voyager à l'étranger au point ce qu'on
peut lire tous les jours ou toutes les
semaines dans le canard et tous les
jours avec des mises en examen et je
crois que c'est cette cette corruption
et le mâle majeur de ce pays parce que
là j'ai des français ce qui pourrait
être une société extraordinairement
agréable devient une société ingérable
parce qu'on n'a plus de respect pour les
élites qui sont du coup à force de 7,2
se permet des accommodements personnel
avec la morale non plus l'autorité pour
demander à la société simplement de
fonctionner normalement
on peut pas demander aux routiers de ne
pas occuper les routes on peut pas
demander aux jeunes des cités pas crever
les pneus pour des pu et dû s'opposer à
des méfaits absolument battre badin
quant au sommet de l'état on s'accorde
des privilèges a perdu tort c'est
d'autant plus grave que la classe
politique française est quand même une
classe politique qui parle de son âme à
longueur de temps
la classe politique française n'arrête
pas de s'appuyer sur des principes qui
est sa [ __ ] allemand de ce qu'elles en
font sous terre et ce langage
il ya une phrase qui est très drôle qui
vous citez dans votre livre de catherine
et un moment où le monde la mort de
bérégovoy qui est à la mode green façon
noble argovien mais elle dit la classe
politique française ne devrait pas
s'habiller en blanc c'est très salissant
et c'est un peu ça notre caste politique
n'arrête pas de donner des leçons de
morale est en fait l état propres forces
et c'est ça le point départ du stade
rennais a une phrase de de gaulle qui en
quittant son bureau disait toujours
éteignez les lumières car il avait le
souci de l'économie de l'économie de
l'état et des économies d'état il payait
lui même un certain nombre de choses et
parfois même les germes qui étaient
déposés sur des monuments aux morts
c'est une autre c'est aussi pour ça si
vous voulez que personnellement j'ai
écrit les messages là vous la plus vous
dites que de gaulle appelait les gens
que je viens de citer les ronge les
ronds
les ronge la même faisant glisser il
était je veux dire il suffit de lire sa
correspondance avec son fils etc
c'est une conception de l'état si vous
voulez et la huent pourquoi je me dis
vous et de la vie vous disiez je suis à
servent avec mitterrand parce que je
crois qu'il a par son talent
extraordinaire sa manière de 2,2
justifier toute sa vie et tous les
retournements de sa vie est d'être
capable de tout justifier d'une certaine
façon il a fait disparaître un certain
nombre de bornes ou en tout cas il a
exprimé
peut-être car les hommes sont en rapport
avec leur temps il a peut être exprimé
d'une façon grandiose à sa façon le fait
qu'un effet les valeurs disparaissait et
qu' il fallait se soucier de soi se
servir plutôt que servir
alors revenons à la couture la et
baisser les yeux ne veux pas qu'on
voulait pas polémiquer
j'ai entendu on te dira même être
jésuites des propos de jean mais c'est
tout à fait normal et utile a rappelé en
tout cas très bien alors votre personnel
s'appelle gérard morel
il est le député maire d'une ville de
banlieue et puis comme il a vu que
et bien que sarkozy accueillant des
landelles et que béraud habillée en cat
que chacun en publiant un apport en soi
premier et c'est donc il se dit
j'aimerais bien écrire une biographie de
barbey d'aurevilly et donc il s'adresse
un jeune journaliste talentueux qui
justement est madore barbe et de rêverie
et ce journaliste vous ressemblent
beaucoup d'ailleurs oui enfin il me
semble beaucoup qu'il y avait aussi
beaucoup de traits de caractère tout
mais plus bas traits de caractère des
attributs à mort elle s'est beaucoup de
moi dans mon règne eu ce que je voulais
raconter c'était évidemment tous ces
hommes politiques qui veulent écrire des
livres
ça m'a donné le déclic d'une image et
ensuite que je voulais c'était pouvoir
passait d'un endroit à un autre dans la
société parisienne pour montrer d'une
part à travers le cas de ce ministre
toutes les façons dont il est amené à
voir de l'argent de façon qui n'est pas
tout à fait nette qui n'est pas moral et
puis autour de ça la société de
connivences qui la sq et lequel un
véritable phénomène de société en france
c'est à dire que aussi bien la classe ce
que la classe médiatico politique sur la
paix la caste médiatico politique est
trop complaisante et c'est un trait de
caractère des seins qui au delà de la
caste médiatique king un trait de
caractère français et médiatique
oui mais c'est pourquoi les journaux
sont comme ça c'est parce que les
français sont comme ça il suffit de voir
d'ailleurs ces jours ci on le voit bien
la sphère clinton c'est aux états unis
c'est tout à fait normal de poser des
questions à sa majesté clinton premier
qui se permet de trouver des stagiaires
au palais royal de washington en france
on ne comprend pas on est resté dans la
société du bon plaisir de lui 14 qui dit
tellement bon plaisir
on a pas on ne demande pas d'explication
je suis venue vers nous que nous
dirigent et ça c'est un travers nacion
il se retrouve d'ailleurs dans tous les
domaines parce que quand bien même des
cons à un atome de pouvoir on est
prévenu lundi qu'elle mettait tenant une
excessive quand on voit le tour de
france tout à l'heure on n'en parlait
richard virenque festina ils sont pris
en flagrant délit deux pages les gens ne
sont pas déçus n'en disent pas mais
comment ça se fait au contraire il les
encourage les réconforter mardi la
presse s'acharne contre vous c'est un
véritable travers national sûr je
voulais le montrer à travers pour ça
qu'on va de la vln venger du mal au dos
qui ce jeune journaliste est le [ __ ] de
ce cet homme a indiqué becker son livre
vous avez vous même été le [ __ ] d'un
peu
j'ai créé des papiers pour des ministres
mais tes papiers
jamais jamais jamais de livre et vous
pensez donc les livres de sarkozy de
beyrouth jack lang de ces gains ont été
écrits par des [ __ ]
non je pense que la plupart je pense que
tant max gallo travail quand jacques
avec jean lacouture travail il fait
sadok qui travaillent il écrit eux il
faut d'abord la fois sur dix ils ne font
pas leur doc il disait dangereux que
documentation c'est déjà en soi un
travail donc je pense que effectivement
je crois qu'ils se font aider je suis
sûr qu'ils l'écrivent mais tu sais pas
ce qu atre là en particulier qu'il faut
citer à chaque fois mais il y en a
plusieurs qui se sont fait prendre au
tour du monde elle de sarkozy il ya une
petite affaire autour des livres déjà
quitté les lieux d affaires de ces
fréquences arriver alors donc il se
trouve donc que le jeune homme adore
parce qu'il adore regarder de rémy donc
il va écrire ce que cet ouvrage mais il
se trouve que est hilare pour maîtresse
une jeune femme singulière qui vient
justement de cette commune de la
banlieue et qui a des dossiers à charge
contre le député maire voilà donc c'est
évidemment le livre sera écrit puis
passera l'été lions d'ailleurs page 130
que vous dites sur moi et donc il est
invité
là je suis pas daccord 1 et alors là la
dame ce que la maison d'édition qui
ressemble bougrement à simone gallimard
je crois qu'on la reconnaît bien elle
comptait envoyé le manuscrit définitif à
l'imprimé ans le 30 avril
le livre sortira le 15 mai puis vous
accepté de recevoir morel un premier
scud vite edel 16
je peux vous assurer que je ne reçois
jamais un homme politique écrit un livre
sans avoir auparavant vraiment regarder
sérieusement le livre jamais et on se
dira pour vous faire une confidence
c'est que quand le livre est bon je me
dis est ce qui aurait pas eu un [ __ ]
derrière et puis quand il est évidement
il est pas bon je n'invite pas quoi
donc ça changerait une émission vers des
[ __ ] ben non parce que mon ne dis pas
que tu sais rien je sais pas c'est pas
du tout sais pas il faut demander mais
alors max gallo vous avez été vous même
un [ __ ] non atteints martin gray au
début n'ont pas non non c'était pas
j'appelle [ __ ] vous savez l'expression
américaine ghost writer écrivain fantôme
c'était pas du tout j'ai écrit le livre
mais mon nom était sur la couverture
ah bon propos recueillis par de max
gallo bon et alors je n'ai pas été élève
des jésuites mais enfin c'était comme ça
bon ce qui est vrai c'est que évidemment
de ya plein d'histoires dans votre livre
qui fait qu'on a la foi vous êtes très
très ironique et très embêtant drôle
c'est vrai surtout ce pari mais pas le
pari médiatique aussi le paris
littéraire et le pari politique et tout
cela on a l'impression qu'il y as tout
ça il ya des sucres des réseaux et tout
ça est un peu pour ont pu écorner dans
le mensonge quoi voilà je crois que oui
c'est une évidence absolue et que ne pas
le voir s'aveugler soi même le lit d
emile louis joos il faut pas de flash
back il faut des scènes alors donc mon
idée c'était d'aller d'un endroit à un
autre vin inde et à une projection
privée un débat là clooney a je sais pas
au grand v tout ça était lundi dernier
un petit peu et au saint père sont tous
les gens se connaissent qu'ils ont tous
des raisons mais une raison on ne fait
jamais les bonnes choses pour des bonnes
raisons
en plus ça le fin fond de scène vous
donner des noms réels d'ailleurs
critique littéraire de nos politiques
l'armée doit viser
on dirait plus souvent la messe le curé
donner donner dans le serment le nom des
gens qui n'ont été annoncés défaut alors
là j'ai effectivement on y va et alors
le net et on finit là dessus non il faut
pas oublier c'est que charles de gaulle
a été le [ __ ] de philippe pétain c'est
vrai bel écran maigre un peu comme le
rebelle c'est vrai et que relation
épistolaire en effet non pas épistolaire
il ya eu aussi des lettres échangées en
fait c'est une relation littéraire dans
laquelle évidemment de gaulle une
certaine manière ce mais devenait
l'officier de plume de cet imperator
dans les années 20 et mais bien sûr il
n'a pas accepté que l'on remanie son
texte et ceux qui trouvaient que il
était capable de mettre sa carrière en
jeu dès lors que ceux qu'ils
considéraient comme essentielle sa
pensée son écriture aussi pouvait être
remise en cause
mais d'ailleurs les tlj à un petit 18
juin mais bon c'est l'homme des rup très
bien les textes qui ont échangé avec les
pépins qu'on retrouve ils sont étonnants
l'appart de gros qui propose six en même
temps très respectueux du maréchal
pétain en même temps disons carrément la
vérité en disant c'est moi qui les ai
écrits et ses bras vous et ainsi de
suite
c'est étonnant on voit des effectivement
son aîné de son foutu caractère et
puisse répondre à des gens il faudrait
prévenir des délits hérarchie entre les
deux mais c'est intéressant de comparer
les hommes de gaulle et est un homme de
rupture
mitterrand est un homme d'addition c'est
pour ça qu'ils transportent tout au long
de sa vie les mêmes amitiés d'une
certaine manière ils les transporte de
gaulle rond il rompt avec son milieu
parce que pour lui il y a des exigences
qui vont au dessus du plaisir d'avoir
des amis de recevoir à table à latche
untel et untel quoi qu'ils aient fait
bien ben voilà donc
j'espère que je sais pas auriez-vous
peut-être un prix littéraire peut-être
le prix interallié qui réservait aux
journalistes parce que même y compris
dans le livre on voit que le [ __ ]
le journaliste à partie un jury
littéraire et le vote pour le livre
qu'il a écrit lui-même souhaité qui est
signé d'une femme politique c'est à dire
maintenant il a la secte là c'est
carrément excessif aura beau alors
pourquoi parrot je me dis que ça devait
rechercher ben oui bah survient alors
terminé pas il ya un de gaulle dans les
dossiers historia en de gaulle en deux
volumes
il ya un charmant livre de gaulle à
colombey la vie quotidienne des de
gaulle par jean paul ollivier aux
éditions plon comment c'était la vie
quotidienne avec les rapports avec le
curé avec les commerçants et autres
celui vient de sortir la face cachée du
gaullisme de nicolas tenzer c'est dallas
chez hachette littératures et puis d'un
aux éditions chronique il y a le charles
de gaulle
et puis dans les chroniques de
l'histoire le charles de gaulle et le
mitterrand je signale notre part aussi
c'est une nouveauté par eric dupin le
disciple où les dix leçons que je sais
pas a pris de mitterrand aux éditions
plon un ouvrage très intéressante est
passionnant c'est la naissance du
panthéon et c'est sur le culte des
grands hommes par jean claude bonnet aux
éditions fayard
c'est vrai que j'ai commencé à le lire
parce que c'est un très très gros livre
et puis si elle aussi les mots de
l'histoire
ben oui c'est l'histoire racontée à part
les mollets aussi les épitaphes duel des
pêches et ainsi de suite
une sorte de survol de l'histoire à
travers les mots c'est publié aux
éditions larousse
et puis enfin ce numéro speller
collection de l'histoire celui ospel
consacré aux années de gaulle et pétain
pour terminer trois conseils alors ça
c'est drôle c'est normal comme syndic
des piles sont comme chez moi c'est
tentant par tous tombent alors trois
conseils pour votre vitesse en dehors
des en plus vient mais en tant que des
ouvrages que que j'ai lu ici et que j'ai
eu un grand plaisir
alors d'abord allé voir au jeu de paume
la rétrospective du peintre alléchant
ski alors qui pour moi qui pour moi
c'est qu'on peut plus dire jénine en
sciences et génie
en tout cas s'il en est pas un mois pour
moi c'est un très très très très grand
peintre
c'est un grand peine parce que il a créé
un monde de formes et de couleurs dont
il est celle j'aime beaucoup dans la
marge son propre commentateurs un
exégète à la fois savant et ironique
déroutant et femmes il y est donc allé
voir cette exposition vraiment admirable
au jeu de paume
et puis alors maintenant la bande
dessinée alors la bande dessinée dans
qui bilal qui s'intitule le sommeil du
monstre
alors est ce que c'est une bd belge bien
que ces pitot louis c'est une bd même
temps c'est davantage est une peinture
ce que bilal est un très très grand
peintre d'un monde absolument terrifiant
monstrueux habité par des hommes et des
femmes auxquels déjà probablement nous
devons nous devons ressembler mais nous
il faut les voir dans celle qui bilal
peut-être serons-nous ainsi dès demain
si nous le sommes déjà
et puis enfin je voudrais pour commander
le film de rohmer qui s'intitule conte
d'automne alors hormis une scène un peu
longuette au début dans une vigne après
c'est un film vraiment délicieux
enchanteur qui raconte les amours de de
la quarantaine et alors c'est plein de
de réticences de qui propos de méprise
ses services en vraiment auquel c'est un
jeune homme remet revoilà eh bien merci
à tous merci à tous les trois bonsoir à
tous et à la semaine prochaine
bouillon de culture avec la fnac
m